dann könnt ihr sagen was es beim ob sein
soll also irgendwie ein skelett oder ein
krieg oder ein schwein oder wasser sich
dann könnt ihr die waffe auswählen ihr
könnt denen den kopf aus wer sich über
eine liebe freunde und herzlich
willkommen hielt du eine runde mycroft
heute zieht allerdings stunden tritt ich
mich nicht aus dem cajun keks spielen
sondern ich werde letzter zeit häufiger
gefragt unter den commands folgen haye
mit dem command und so da ist ein 1 1
bietet typ bildet übler in lucka bei den
commands und so da ist es ja so wie soll
man sich denn da selber commands
ausdenken was gibt es denn da für coole
sachen kann es eventuell irgendwas
empfehlen oder irgendwie so und zwar
habe ich da letztens eine website
mehrfach zugesendet bekommen wo wir
sowieso fällig die tür nicht aufmachen
habe in letzter zeit immer wieder so die
frage bekommen hell wie die sonne das
machen mit dem command sich mal
natürlich kann man welche aus dem
internet nehmen ich hab gesagt da gibt
es eine regel wie dich ist geklaut wird
irgendwie so sondern das könnte
natürlich irgendwo aus dem internet
nehmen oder so allerdings habe ich auch
einige gefragt wie kann man sich dann
selber commands ausdenken und ich habe
davon natürlich nicht so viel ahnung
allerdings habe ich mich dann einfach
mal bemüht mich das ein bisschen und
geschaut den toni wird auch eine sache
extrem auf zugesendet und zwar jetzt
laufe ich wieder an diese blöde falle
reine es war wurde mir extrem oft gesagt
ausgetrickst getrickst sowie ihr wurde
extrem auf eine website zu gewinnen und
zwar heißt diese website minecraft
updates dot com schrägstrich zusammen -
command und zwar ist es eine website wo
man sich selber commands ausdenken kann
du kannst du einfach hingehen und ich
blende ich das jetzt einfach mal ein da
kannst du deine e-mail-adresse eintragen
wenn er ihr gesagt werden wollt also das
müsst ihr nicht machen sondern das macht
er halt nur wenn ihr sagt ja ich möchte
bei updates informiert sein
dann könnt ihr da halt so was eingeben
wie der command dass man entweder an
sbornaja ich werde gerade geboxt alter
nein ich bin total lösen
da könnt ihr dann einfach sagen guck mal
ob ihren mops tonnen wollt einfach oder
ob wir gleich ein ganzes borna dafür
haben wollt dann könnt ihr sagen was ist
beim ob sein soll das irgendwie ein
skelett oder antrieb oder schwein oder
was weiß ich
dann könnt ihr die waffe auswählen ihr
könnt denen den kopf auswählen als ihr
könnt da sagen ja der soll so und so
kopf haben aber sollen eigentlich ein
skelett sein und so ihr könnt sagen was
das für eine rüstung an haben soll was
es für eine bein rüstung an haben soll
was es für schuhe anhaben soll so was
möglich ist alles und ihr könnt sogar
noch da irgendwelche in chats hinzufügen
also das ist viel
irgendwie halt noch ein paar
eigenschaften hat oder irgendwie so
komischen effekt mob options ganz ganz
viele sachen könnt ihr einfach absammeln
klickt man bekommt hier unten einen
roman tante zeigt und der sport dann
quasi eurem ob in minecraft in den könnt
ihr dann wenn ihr wollten wir senden
allerdings bitte nur wenn er kreativ ist
also jetzt nicht so was wie hat es einen
termin mit dem helm auf
da denke ich mir dann einfach nur okay
das ist sehr sehr kreativ es ist nicht
so dass ich zu wenig command zugesendet
bekommen um noch eine folge zu machen
oder irgendwie so ich habe unendlich
viele commands mail zugesendet werden
aber es ist halt einfach so viele leute
schreiben mir die macht man dann solche
kommando steht gar nicht und das hat die
website ihr euch dabei hilde also an
alle die jetzt immer mein sohn du hast
ein schwarzes t shirt an und bekommt von
marke xy zehn millionen euro dafür
ich werde nicht von dieser website
bezahlt ich glaube auf der website ist
nicht mehr werbung oder so das heißt ich
oder ich weiß gar nicht ob der werbung
ist ich glaube der ist aber ich weiß
nicht von wem die website ist ein extrem
auf zugesendet und die button machen
dabei quasi auch so sachen wie die haben
sollen fireworks im juli lakers sammeln
oder so wo man auch das gleiche wie mit
dem mob commands kann man dann noch mal
für ein feuerwerk machen also du kannst
dann einfach sagen ja ich hätte gern ein
feuerwerk mit den farben in denen den
abständen soll das pons und so groß soll
das werden deshalb mega cool das ist
halt einfach eine seite die einem hilft
und ich dachte einfach dass wir ganz
cool das passt zu der command sache und
da könnt ihr einfach mal vorbeikommen
den krediten ihre spitzen spitzen ich
mache ich möchte ich meinen kommunalen
spitzen und das war es auch eigentlich
stand schon von von diesem video und
zwar wo ist jetzt auch dieser dieser
blog ist da hinten weggeköpfelt der
tyler perry und jetzt vorbei ist aber
eigentlich auch ganz gut und zwar der
schwede ist eva bei ich wollte euch
quasi nur sagen hey ich habe so eine
seite entdeckt die ist ganz cool
deswegen kommt dass jetzt auch neben dem
video was ich muss mal ganz gut sagt
guck mal das video habt kommt weil ich
wieder über vier tage beruflich weg bin
deswegen müsste nämlich ein echtes
machen deswegen ich habe nachgeschaut
deswegen kommt das video auch heute nur
am montagabend und deswegen hattet ihr
auch heute nachmittag schon ein video
von einer app und zwar vom dort ab war
das ja ich plane das immer extrem genau
und deswegen ist es nur ein kleines
video nebenbei eine runde einzieht wo
ich dann eben kurz drüber reden über die
website finde ich eigentlich ganz gut
deswegen da könnte einfach mal
vorbeischauen wenn ihr möchtet der link
ist auch irgendwie eine beschreibung
sonst liegt er halt nicht drauf oder ihr
euch gefällt die website nicht oder
sonstwas nur einfach da könnt ihr quasi
eigenen commands machen ich möchte euch
damit eine kleine hilfestellung leisten
und dann würde ich sagen ich fühle mich
in meiner bewertung freuen sind wie wird